blacking out like your dad on Christmas
using live ammunition when blanks would
do just fine and getting jaw surgery
seriously man how about some invisaline
next time whether you like these movies
or not you have to respect or maybe fear
what these actors did to perform in them
drawing from the various performers who
had played the role before her shout out
Debbie Dairy Berry so pathetic as well
as adding plenty of her own flavor to
the mix it's tough to imagine anyone
else but Jenna Orga playing the Adam's
daughter in Wednesday as usual you
underestimate me mother it's not as easy
as it seems to have a cold dead pan look
and delivery without making your
performance wooden asked Hillary
Duff Wednesday isn't emotionless she
just does her best not to wear those
emotions all over her face corny Cox
would later try this in real
life to play the part orer leaned into
Wednesday director Tim Burton's love of
the kubric stair a technique that
frequently appears in both my wedding
photos and the films of director Stanley
cubrick in which an actor slightly tilts
the head downward or looking up with
just their eyes imagine you're ordering
a Chipotle but like way scarier than
that she also decided that Wednesday
should never blink she was able to get
all of the blinking in whenever the
camera wasn't on her I do the same
thing somehow Ora managed to pull it all
off without looking like a freshly
incarcerated Hannibal Lector that awful
screaming of the Lambs okay so if you
watch Step Brothers before watching
parks and wreck it might take a minute
to not hate Ben Wyatt
what in Step Brothers where he is every
single butthole you've ever met his
introduction takes a cake of butt
Holiness this is $1,200 a week for voice
lessons and this is what I get Adam
Scott's character Derek is leading his
family in an or capella and addition of
your dad's favorite Classic Rock ballad
Sweet Child of Mine remarkably all of
the singing in the scene was done live
but it wasn't done by all of the actors
Adam Scott in a word sucks ass at
singing and I can sing
so in order to sell the idea that Derek
can actually sing and expects nothing
less of his wife and children a
professional singer had to be brought in
the scene would have been ruined if you
could tell he was lip syncing so the
real actually good singer was made to
stands not only outside of the car but
directly in front of it the car you see
was stationary on a Sound Stage this was
done to avoid burdening Adam with
vehicular manslaughter as he sang
Scott's eyes had to remain fixed on the
singer's mouth gross which allowed him
to IM the professional singer the butth
holy nature of the rest of the character
though that was all Adam Scott you guys
both look like you might want to hit me
in the
face after a few minor television rolls
she was the bomman that came from out of
space I'm a witness so M me too all
three of us oh AE how can I ever thank
you Holly Berry's breakthrough
performance came by way of her powerful
portrayal of Vivien in Spike Le's jungle
fever it was a role she had to fight
hard to even be considered for as Lee
felt Barry was too attractive to be
taken seriously as a down andout drug
addict he felt let the record show that
she was not too attractive to be taken
seriously as his wife in the movie which
was his original intent Barry pushed for
the role of viven and eventually
convinced him to let her play the part
which launched her film career Barry
didn't want to waste the opportunity she
had been given that would come much
later with 2004
Catwoman she wanted to make sure the
audience wouldn't think she was too
clean cut or pretty to be taken
seriously as Vivian so she decided to go
to the method acting route and stopped
bathing for several weeks in order to
get into character as someone who had
been living a rough life on the streets
she would later think metaphorically in
2004's Catwoman time to accessorize some
of Barry's co-stars kept their distance
during her shower Hiatus much like
audiences did for 2004 Catwoman cat got
your tongue I'm cracking out the
Catwoman jokes today boys but it was
clearly worth it in the long run as her
performance in Jungle Fever put her on
the past to a long and prolific movie
career except for 2004's cutwoman one
more joke for good measure Wen Phoenix
is undeniably one of the greatest actors
working today he was not in 2004's
Catwoman
per okay I'll stop now and he's among a
select group that is known to completely
disappear into their roles he didn't
kill anybody while making joker as far
as we know but otherwise he never seems
to back down from an acting challenge
what what is the character so you didn't
you haven't read it for Paul Thomas
Anderson's the master Phoenix plays a
World War II veteran named Freddy quell
Freddy is shall we say not exactly a
cool hang he's very quiet but tightly
wound and to play him Phoenix Drew
inspiration from his sounds like an
absolute ton of fun father is this bie
make poison now if you drink it smart he
told NPR my dad sometimes would talk out
to the side he'd clenched down oneide of
his mouth and I just thought it
represented tension in this way somebody
that's just blocked and T night instead
of self-inducing constipation or tying
himself up like a rodeo ball Fenix
thought I'll just use brute
force Fenix decided to have his dentist
add metal brackets and rubber bands to
his teeth which forced half of his jaw
shirt ensuring a constantly shy side
mouthed appearance remember that time
the rock laid to smack down on some
chains no I didn't see that movie either
no matter what you might think about the
caliber of Dwayne Johnson's acting
abilities or the projects he appears in
can I get a little help here there's
accusing the former wrestler of phoning
it in when it comes to no pain no gain
for him Pain and Gain Is Not only an
IMDb results but also a life motto sanss
All the murder hopefully he genuinely
puts his body through the meat grinder
to play the tan beeron he often plays us
team Jesus Christ and anyone who doubts
that needs to hear how his character
escaped bondage while filming 2014's
Hercules and not the bondage you're
thinking
of there is a scene in the movie where
the rock needs to break free from change
to bind his glistening hairless arms
Johnson being way more Ken than Alan I'm
Alan I'm I'm Ken's buddy insisting on
using real thick steel chains to film
The Struggle obviously not even
Johnson's impressive pecs can pop out of
that so some movie Magic would be needed
to actually break the chains but up to
that point Johnson was fighting and
straining against two chains in fact
Johnson ended up blacking out in each of
the eight takes because he was going so
hard reminds me of college so it's like
I am
and then I black out the hangover was a
massive comedy hit about three friends
putting their lives back together after
a wild night in Vegas and in fact not a
documentary about how mixing uppers and
downers is awesome Ed Helms plays a
dentist named Stu who wakes up to
discover that he really effing needs a
dentist eventually Stu discovers that he
extracted the tooth himself drawing his
drunken stup POR in an effort to impress
his friends worst party trick ever early
in the movie when Stu looks in the
mirror we get a clear shot of the studio
apartment occupying the space where his
tooth used to be this rules out the
usual blackout job that is typically
done to achieve the missing tooth effect
in movies Helms told people we started
to do different tests with prosthetics
and blacking it out and nothing worked
so then Ed thoughts I'll just use brute
force it just so happens that one of
Helm's front teeth was fake as he had an
implant him when he was a teenager Helm
was revealed that he volunteered to have
that tooth removed and an implant that
had been in Helm's Mouse for nearly 20
years was emphatically Marie condo for
the sake of art does this item spark Joy
if does not get R of it Robert dairo
best known as the dad and meet the
[__] apparently got nominated for a
ton of oscars early in his career who
knew one of those nominations was for
the 1978 Vietnam War drama the deer
hunter the film was the first movie he
ever made a million dollars on and he
certainly worked hard for that payday
spoiler alerts he almost blew his brains
out dairo has described his experience
playing staff sergeant Mike ronsky as
some of the most physically and
emotionally exhausting work he's ever
done as an actor right up there I
imagine with his harrowing turn as
fearless leader in Rocky and
Bullwinkle are you talking to
me there is a moment in the movie where
Mike puts a gun directly to the head of
Stanley and pulls the trigger always
wanting to push himself to give the most
believable performance possible dairo
asked director Michael chimino if there
could be a live round in the gun even
Nerf darts are too intense for me
chimino pointed out that this would mean
literally playing Russian moulette with
John cazals life but dairo told him the
gun could be rigged so that it wouldn't
fire that round remind me to never go in
the woods of Mr [__] remarkably both
chimino and kazal obliged to request and
Dao went on to earn an Oscar nomination
for his performance if things had gone
wrong he may have earned life in prison
and we would have missed out on such
Classics as Analyze That Stardust and
Las
Vegas the cast of the live action and
also terrible According to some
Scooby-Doo was a veritable who's who of
young Hollywood at the time with the
role of munching craving scaredy cat
cool but we won't go into why noville
Shaggy Rogers going to Matthew Lillard
of scream
Fame for much of Shaggy's existence the
character have been voiced by your
Boomer Grandma's favorite radio DJ Casey
kasm kasm gave Shaggy a voice that
sounded perpetually hoarse as if he was
constantly taking a drag from a totally
legal cigarette so when it came time for
Lillard to do the voice he replicated
the sounds not by inhaling the air at a
fish concert but by literally screaming
himself into a sore throat I'm Mary Jane
like that is my favorite name really
lard got so good at it he was able to do
it without all the screaming and went on
to voice Shaggy in the majority of the
characters multimedia appearances he
didn't take over any of kum's other jobs
though if you were born before 1980 you
probably consider adventures in
babysitting a staple of your childhood
and by staple I mean puberty Catalyst
hello Elizabeth Shu hi the 1987 comedy
follows Angelic Chris Parker who was
stood up by the most douchy named 80s
boyfriend ever Mike todwell
see you around Mike and as a result
stumbles into a wild night full of crazy
oh Thor Mighty God of Thunder who is
this kid among those along for the ride
is Brad who and this is my favorite
sentence in entire video gets his foot
stabbed during a gang fight on a
train while rehearsing the scene the
casting crew were trying to figure out
the best way to stab him in the foot
last one actor Keith kougan who would
later grow his hair and kill the
babysitter in an entirely different
movie about babysitting dishes are done
man came up with the idea of pulling the
knife from the shoe and just playing the
shot in reverse the idea worked much to
the relief of Keith's toes a lot of
unsavory accusations came out during the
high-profile 2022 courtroom battle
between trash couple Johnny Depp and
Amber herd we don't have to nor do we
want to get into all of them but one
sticks out because it was professional
in nature and involved absolutely no
beds or poop Depp's former agent Tracy
Jacobs claimed that Deb wore an ear
peace on set to have his lines fed to
him like he was on an episode of
Impractical Jokers I leave negative
yelper reviews on my wife's noodle shop
I leave negative Yelp reviews from my
wife's noodle shop this claim was one of
several examples she used to support to
ass that Depp's talent and commitment to
his work had declined in recent years
she also I imagine just want an excuse
for the Fantastic Beast movies however
Keenan Wyatt a sound engineer who has
collaborated with Depp on many of his
films said that Depp wears an Erp not
for lines but to listen to music
probably not his own he stated it helps
Deb get into and stain character Deb had
previously said the same thing in a 2018
interview with rolling stone asserting
the earpiece he wears is to listen to
music and other sounds that help him
feel the emotions he needs to express in
the moment perhaps drawing fantastic
Beast he listened to imagin dragons and
imagined himself in a better movie so
what makes Johnny cry besides being
married to real life Harley Quinn Amber
herd the actor explained I've got bag
pipes a baby crying and bombs going off
it creates a truth some of my biggest
Heroes were in silent film it had to be
behind the eyes and my feeling is that
if there's no truth behind the eyes
Doesn't Matter Where theing words are
bag pipes man I Get It season 2 of The
White Lotus is essentially eight hours
of Rich drunk people being horrible to
each other and Orbee Plaza was so good
at it she got nominated for an Emy on
the show she plays harpa Spiller who
starts the very April lgate from Parks
and wreck before morphing into entitled
misbehaving April lgate from Parks and
wck as the season progresses Harper's
drinking intensifies leading to Plaza
having to portray Harper more and more
drunk rather than putting in an earpiece
and listening to sounds of someone
ripping shots of Don hulio Sila she
would literally spin around in circles
and make herself dizzy before filming
scenes spinning less or more depending
on how smash she needed to be next time
Aubrey just meet me at Patty's
[Music]
pup